jürgen drews redet gerne und viel und
das mit recht der mann hat mir viel zu
erzählen zum beispiel zum thema ob er
ein berufsjugendlicher ist und ob er in
einem anderen zeitalter nicht vielleicht
eingewiesen worden wäre eine berechtigte
frage wie ich finde ich rede mit ihm
über das verhältnis zu seinen kindern
ich vertiefe das noch mal und da kommt
es unter anderem auch auf seinen vater
zu sprechen und ja das und noch viel
mehr wobei viel mehr kann man in dem
fall nicht sagen weil er redet schon
sehr ausführlichen ich muss in dem fall
sagen nicht alle fragen sind dran
gekommen aber wenn ihr noch mehr von
jürgen drews sieht da oben ist irgendwo
der abo button button nicht vergessen
den zu drücken bis dahin bleibt dran
ich habe ich irgendwas ausgenommen sind
wahrscheinlich weiter parametern können
sind gemeine fragen die grünen sinn
haben nur so frank fragen über otto du
kannst selber wählen was du möchtest und
ja
also endlich mal sehr aber es mir
gelingt das einer rausfällt krone der
sagen muss was es für eine frage ist es
war schön grün
ja es bleibt grün während siehst du ich
glaube zwar an so was nur bedingt ich
bin ein positiver mensch ich bin
wirklich ja ich bin kein mensch der
irgendwie im schaden will oder wollten
immer nur an das beste und das schönste
genau die die unteren ende einfach
abdrehen wieder einmal wird das sagt ach
ja und so ist es nicht das erste mal
dass das nein ich bin da sehr beengt ja
da bin ich behinderten viel blöder
ausdrücken aber falsche worte wenn diese
urbane herrlich hier steht was macht
dich so
einzigartig
ja was man sagt er würde könnte ich
jetzt wieder angucken was soll ich
machen sollte was
ist dein man sagt ja immer dass die usb
oder alleinstellungsmerkmal ist es dann
nicht ganz das us- team an das kann ich
nicht wie usb unique selling proposition
munich sales prozesse genau
alles merken
hahaha ich
habe es eben schon mal erwähnt
vielleicht dass ich auf deubel komm raus
auch wenn man es gegen mich verwenden
kann fast immer nicht fasst eigentlich
immer das sage was ich denke und das ist
nicht immer das richtige ich habe das
für ihn als fehler bezeichnet
aber das macht mich vielleicht ein wenig
unique
ok
werden jetzt noch mehr nicht nur ein
hast du dort ist nun noch mal
wählen bei uns fallen also dagegen habe
ich auch kein problem geworden sind
bitte ich eine rast ist die rot ist so
dann hast du deine hose kommst du dir
als berufsjugendlicher nicht super blöd
vor
wenn ich ein berufsjugendlicher wäre
bisher nicht würde ich mir so blöd
vorkommen aber bist du nicht ich kann
nichts dafür dass ich so bin wie ich bin
was euch nun ändern
ich muss meinem alter entsprechend ich
muss mich jetzt abschalten was meinst du
das ist einmal wenn achtziger jahren
jemand in deinem alter so um gelaufen
wäre hätte man doch eingewiesen
ja das ist ein schöner
verein gewesen hätte nein das ist ja das
schöne dass ich tempora mutantur wie
sich die zeiten ändern sagte schon
als ich den könig von mallorca gesagt
habe den ich bin der könig von mallorca
die ich mehrmals abgelehnt habe den
titel hast du alles an mir ja
irgendwann schickt diese völlig
entnervte komponist und texter
diesen titel in meine klitschen
diskothek wird die ich habe in die
kulisse in düsseldorf ja wie heißt sie
die kulisse in düsseldorf bitteschön
geschickt das da hin der rief mich an
der decke sagt alter ich habe den titel
zugeschickt bekommen musst du sie sagen
etwas für an ich bin der könig von
mallorca kröte mit das mikrofon er hat
das telefon gesagt bist du wahnsinnig ja
sagte ich hab das schon goethes april
dass die leute haben das geld nach er
wird geglaubt hab ich ja weißt du was es
nervt mich jetzt ich war gerade dabei
meine lp fertigzustellen ich nur
deswegen auf macht dass unser
unter ferner liefen als letzten titel
oder so vorletzten sie glaubt dass
darauf gemacht das sollte aber nicht der
letzte streich gewesen sein denn da noch
rege ich mich ein ganz bekannter
privatsender an und sagt da würdest du
folgendes tun wir haben eine titel von
dir gehört den wir sehr interessant
finden sie finden sie beschissen aber
ich finde ihn sehr interessant würdest
du dir einen umhang und eine krone
aufsetzen und dich in sichtweite des
kreuzes von teenie ludwig den zweiten im
starnberger see versenken und dabei noch
singen so als letzte bevor die unter
blanc ich bin ich
sagt die idee ist geil das heißt du
willst es machen sagt ja aber da sagen
deswegen habe ich mich versenkt mit der
krone und habe wirklich gedacht dass die
bild zeitung mit der schlagzeile öffnet
jetzt ist er ganz wahnsinnig geworden
drews reif für die insel oder wofür auch
immer so gemeint was wirst du noch
konnte noch keine letzte frage an uns
gern muss aber rot sein ja ich hatte mir
ist das kürzeste fragen wollte was wir
überhaupt bisher hatten wir sitzen wir
ja morgen früh also na ja ich will
wirklich witzig dabei muss ich jetzt
gleich auf die bühne ja bist du ein
schlechter vater ja
definitiv in welcher form nicht dass ich
meinen sohn nicht liebe
das entscheidungs kind jetzt sehr viel
heulen müssen rotz und wasser weil
er kriegt das nicht geregelt ich
übrigens auch nicht dass das mit
corinna halt nicht mehr klappte
und dann ist ja aufs internat gegangen
ich dachte viel kann ich es so kippen
internat in england
hat art & design studiert und arbeitet
auch sein level dort gemacht und ich
dachte wie krieg ist wieder gebacken in
dem ich corinna waage corinna bitte
ich sage dir ruft mich vorher an ich
sage die apra monat zu hause sind wenn
sie zu hause ist und ich unterwegs bin
klingel gehen die tiere werk ramona ich
möchte mit dir reden sorry
ich habe mich nicht richtig benommen sie
gegenüber springen über deinen schatten
im namen unseres sohnes
und lasst uns zusammen bitte nach
england fahren du mit deinem mann ich
mit ramona bitte ich habe das nicht nur
einmal gesagt und dadurch ich bin allein
in ihn gefahren ich bedauere es zutiefst
ich habe ihn nie besucht in england wir
verstehen uns wieder wir lieben uns
wirklich wie ihr leben ist mir sehr sehr
ähnlich in vielen sachen legte er macht
jetzt dabei minimal techno legt er auf
jetzt in london hat er mich gerade von
angriffen ist jetzt vier stunden her
kommt mit einem land gesagt habe ich
würde so gerne ich kann mich ich bin auf
seine promotion tour für wenn die
wunderkerzen
auch ihr habt noch also wir haben auch
zwischendurch bis 40 jahren als hätte
den letzten 30 jahren einer nein wir
haben einen guten kontakt ich habe auch
zu corinna kontakt ramona sagt das nicht
mehr das war zu viel das ist zu viel
hammer ist eine pragmatikerin
und jetzt mal jolina
ich muss ihn irgendwann packen das hört
ja keiner was ich jetzt sagen na das
wird kleiner ich muss sie packen ich
muss sie ich will sie nehmen und mit dir
irgendwo hinfahren ich weiß noch mein
vater war komischerweise ähnlich er hat
nicht irgendwann mal doch gepackt und
ist mit mir wer ich bin in
schleswig-holstein groß geworden ist
schleswig holstein in schleswig in
schleswig-holstein groß geworden wenn
ich irgendwann gepackt hat sich in
weißensee sommer weißen anzug hatte der
an sagt gail also ein französischer typ
reiters und
ist mit mir nach dänemark gefahren sind
wir über nacht geblieben ich kann mich
noch genau erinnern wie viel spazieren
gegangen sind wir haben ja irgendwas
über die an über raketentechnik erklärt
hat heute finden die juristen gerade
handel das publikum klatscht und so war
der erste sport nicht von dem aus das
erste der wettkampf zwischen usa und er
war sehr sehr beschlagen sind
intellektuell eigentlich gewesen
das war nicht toll ich habe ihn auf den
lippen jetzt überwältigt mich richtig
und wenn mich das überwältigt wird es
doch mal zeit dass ich das auch marina
paris wohl simulieren lassen
tatsache ist okay